e tutta questione di tempo
siamo tutti fissati col tempo vogliamo
organizzarlo definirlo deciderlo e
migliorarlo significa migliorare noi
stessi perché conoscere il tempo ci fa
capire la nostra realtà ci fa sentire
vivi presenti in gas swatch noi siamo
l'unica specie umana presente qui e
adesso
noi siamo il risultato di un'evoluzione
fatta a regola d'arte
non solo ci siamo evoluti ma siamo in
continuo a prayer what it takes
e se vogliamo anche migliorare il mondo
il dalai lama ha detto che dobbiamo
prima migliorare noi stessi
beh personalmente trovo difficile
migliorare se stessi se non sappiamo il
nostro passato gli errori che abbiamo
fatto
se non sappiamo chi fumo e lasciatemi
passare questa imprecisione usando
l'allegoria con napoleone e il passato
remoto come modo per enfatizzare un
passato vecchio di 40 mila anni un
passato glorioso
che ci ha portato fin qui oggi
e quindi anche noi fummo
nell'affascinante storia dell'evoluzione
umana dove però in questo caso la
consapevolezza del tempo che fu
è scandita dall orologio atomico per
eccellenza il radiocarbonio
ora conoscere come funziona e radio
carbonia i suoi miglioramenti nel campo
dell'evoluzione umana è fondamentale se
vogliamo
upgrade
io sono sarà talamo e sono un'archeologa
che studia il ticchettio del tempo che
fu e come tutti voi sono ossessionata
dall avere un orologio che scandisca in
modo preciso il tempo
sì però il tempo del nostro arrivo in
europa il tempo del nostro incontro con
loro e per loro non intendo mostri
alieni che vengono da marte intendo i
nostri cugini più prossimi i
neandertaliani
quindi ho bisogno di un orologio che
scandisca i minuti ei secondi
intorno ai 40.000 anni fa sì perché
proprio in quel periodo l'europa era al
centro di uno dei più affascinanti
eventi dell'evoluzione umana ossia
l'incontro della nostra specie con i
neandertaliani
ora cosa sia successo esattamente quando
noi homo sapiens usciamo dall africa
arriviamo in europa e incontriamo i
nostri cugini più prossimi e ancora un
argomento un po velato dal mistero
quello che sappiamo con esattezza è che
i neandertaliani hanno popolato l'europa
per
400.000 anni più o meno contemporanea
alla nascita dell'homo sapiens in africa
poi si sono diffusi per tutta l'asia
medio orientale fino alla siberia e
grazie all'abbondante documentazione
fossile sappiamo abbastanza bene la loro
anatomia la loro dieta i loro movimenti
sappiamo che si organizzavano in
accampamenti che erano abili cacciatori
e che fabbricavano utensili manufatti
litici
abbastanza complessi ma anche ripetitivi
avevano un pensiero simbolico e grazie
allo studio della palio genetica
sappiamo che hanno interagito
fisicamente con noi
ma soprattutto che poco dopo la nostra
intera in europa si sono estinti
ora nonostante questa marea di
informazioni le ragioni dietro la loro
scomparsa il nostro successo adattativo
sono ancora uno è ancora uno degli
argomenti più dibattuti nel campo
dell'evoluzione umana
rispondere a domande quando arriviamo in
europa per quanto tempo abbiamo
condiviso il territorio siamo stati noi
che abbiamo influenzato la loro cultura
e perché si sono estinti che noi
sopravvissuti ora rispondere a queste
domande è fondamentale se vogliamo
capire chi fumo e il successo che ci ha
portato fin qui oggi è la soluzione
sta tutta nella precisione che diamo del
tempo che fu e quindi che cos'è il
radiocarbonio
è un dono del cielo perché si forma
nell'alta atmosfera viene incorporato in
tutti gli organismi viventi e decade con
il passare del tempo
ora questo del ca di mento di tipo beta
di 5.700 30 anni è il dono del cielo
perché questo tipo di decadimento questa
velocità è unica ed è in questo modo che
quando analizziamo la quantità di
carbonio 14 in un campione un organico
riusciamo a determinarne l'età della
loro morte andando indietro fino ai 55
mila anni
l'unico suo difetto se così vogliamo
vederlo e che la quantità di carbonio 14
nell'atmosfera non è rimasta costante e
questo non ci permette di dare
direttamente un'età calendario ma per
ottenerla dobbiamo calibrare la nostra
data carbonio 14 con un calendario
indipendente ed ecco che nasce la curva
di calibrazione
che per i primi 14 mila anni è molto
precisa perché abbiamo gli alberi ma
dopo i 14 mila anni dove gli alberi non
vengono più analizzati la curva perde di
gran lunga la sua precisione più si va
indietro nel tempo più le date diventano
imprecise con errori molto grandi
ora questa situazione lascia noi
scienziati navigare in un mare di
precisione e soprattutto quando vogliamo
parlare dell'incontro tra la nostra
specie quella neandertaliana
questo tipo di imprecisione equivarrebbe
si è riportata in un periodo storico che
marie curie si siede al fianco di
archimede al congresso di soleil invece
di essere seduta tra max planck e
einstein
bene cosa stiamo facendo noi per
migliorare questo metodo perché il
radiocarbonio ha sempre etichettato con
due lancette
ma per aumentare l'accuratezza degli
intervalli di tempo che scandiscono il
corso della nostra storia
c'è bisogno di aggiungerne una terza e
per farlo c'è bisogno di unire diverse
discipline e diversi punti di vista ora
la mia linea di ricerca fa proprio
questo unisce discipline come la
botanica la fisica la chimica e
l'umanistica in un modo altamente
innovativo
e il primo step è proprio la ricerca dei
nostri tanto amati alberi fossili quelli
che hanno reso così precisa la curva per
i primi 14 mila anni ma che dopo non
vengono più analizzati ma le foreste
fossili in europa ci sono basta cercarle
e noi ne abbiamo trovata una sulle
sponde del portogallo sotto l'oceano
atlantico vecchia di 30 milani
il secondo step è un po più complicato
perché sfrutta la sincronicità degli
isotopi cosmogenesi del carbonio 14 e
del berillio 10 e questo ci permette di
unire le nostre date di carbonio 14
ottenuta dagli anelli degli alberi ha
un'età calendario ottenuta dalla
presenza annuale del berillio 10 nelle
carote di ghiaccio della groenlandia e
parolo uno è sì un po così ma quello che
dovete capire che questo metodo ci aiuta
a costruire piccoli pezzi della curva
sempre più precisi
ma come tutti i metodi importanti c'è
sempre un però
che per farlo c'è bisogno di un
elevatissima precisione ossia di un
errore carbonio 14 14 piccolissimo
intorno ai 300 anni beh cosa direi un po
difficile visto che tipicamente per un
campione di 42mila nino teniamo un
errore di 1.700 anni più o meno il che
ecco perché marie curie si siede al
fianco di archimede
ma grazie alla collaborazione dei fisici
che utilizzano il più avanzato modello
in macchina per le datazioni
siamo riusciti ad ottenere per questo
periodo di tempo un errore mai avuto
prima
bene
cosa questo nuovo orologio a tre
lancette fa migliorare
miglior nello studio dell'evoluzione
umana
e io inizierei così
c'era una volta bacio kiro una
famosissima grotta in bulgaria dove a
partire dagli anni 70 viene ritrovato un
industria litica associata all'homo
sapiens più moderna sofisticata
superiore rispetto al paleolitico medio
che è quello associato i neandertaliani
e viene chiamata paleolitico iniziale
superiore
bene a partire dal 2015 si riapre lo
scavo della grotta troviamo altrettante
e l'etica ma anche ornamenti gioielli e
soprattutto nuovi fossili umani
ora potevo immaginarmi la mia
eccitazione quando le trovate perché ho
detto qua posso e devo usare il nuovo
orologio a tre lancette e così facendo
siamo riusciti a dare un'età precisa
dell'homo sapiens di bacio chi lo
abbiamo potuto dire che il primo uomo
finora trovato in europa e direttamente
datato ha un'età di 46 mila anni
bene questa data ha rivoluzionato un po
lo studio dell'evoluzione umana perché
ci ha permesso anche di rispondere in
modo più preciso la prima parte della
seconda domanda ossia quanto per quanto
tempo abbiamo condiviso il territorio
bene noi sappiamo che i neandertaliani
sono scomparsi intorno ai 39 mila anni e
quindi hanno interagito per un massimo
di 7000 anni duemila anni in più di
quello che si pensava precedentemente
ora per rispondere alla seconda parte di
questa domanda
siamo stati noi che le abbiamo ispirati
dobbiamo ricordarci che per
300.000 anni i neanderthal ritoccano
maneggiano e forgiano gli stessi pezzi
di litica il cosiddetto paleolitico
medio ma un certo punto cambiano dove
quando e soprattutto
perché
bene uno dei tanti esempio uno degli
esempi che faccio oggi che lo shuttle
per ron che è una delle tante industrie
cosiddette di transizione viene fatta in
francia viene fatta direttamente dai
neanderthal tra i quaranta 4500 i 40mila
anni in questa industria si trovano
anche ornamenti e gioielli bene ora se
li paragoniamo
agli ornamenti gioielli ritrovati in
bulgaria ai fatti dall'homo sapiens a 46
mila anni vediamo le similitudini e
allora possiamo rispondere sì ne abbiamo
ispirati si
provavano a copiarci ma del resto è
tipico della specie umana non se no
perché abbiamo fatto il copyright è però
non solo ci copiavano
ma facevano anche un'altra cosa che è
tipica della specie umana che piace
molto fare la specie umana e qui
nicoletta landi potrebbe spiegarlo
meglio di me ma quello che io vi posso
dire è che grazie a questo errore così
piccolo questa data così precisa i pali
o genetisti anno ci un anno tarato
meglio il loro orologio molecolare e
così siamo riusciti a dire che questo
homo sapiens deriva da un accoppiamento
e possiamo anche dire di routine per
l'epoca
tra una donna sapiens è un uomo
neandertaliano tra le 5 e le 7
generazioni precedenti
ma non solo che loro di che il suo dna
non ha contribuito per niente al nostro
europeo ma ha contribuito a quello
dell'america e dell'asia attuale
quindi questo che cosa ci dice
ci dice che la nostra evoluzione in
europa è stata particolarmente
complicata che siamo usciti più volte
dall africa sia la prima volta magari
eravamo molto probabilmente anche belli
e intelligenti visto che si copiavano e
ci
maneggiavano
ma è solo con la seconda volta che
abbiamo successo che conquistiamo
l'intero pianeta e che neandertaliani
scompaiono
bene allora cosa rispondiamo alla
domanda che ci farà capire
che ci farà capire il nostro successo
che ci farà capire la creazione del
genere umano attuale perché sono
scomparsi
al momento ci sono diverse ipotesi
alcune veritiere e altre un po meno ma
il fatto è che per testarle c'è bisogno
del nostro orologio a tre lancette
perchè come avete potuto capire c'è
bisogno di creare una più accurata e più
precisa linea del tempo che scandisca in
modo preciso gli eventi della nostra
storia e noi ci stiamo lavorando del
resto facciamo scienza e non miracoli e
per la scienza ma credo anche per i
miracoli c'è sempre bisogno di tempo
[Applauso]
[Musica]